deep learning Falls within machine
learning and machine learning is a
component of artificial intelligence the
interconnectedness of these concept can
be linked to the concentric circles
where artificial intelligence
encompasses the broadest scope followed
by the machine learning and finally the
Deep learning while these terms are
commonly used interchangeably they hold
distinct meaning Beyond merge buzzb
associated with futuristic Technologies
like self-driving cars for those not
emerged in the world of data science the
term artificial intelligence machine
learning and deep learning may sound
elusive the video aims to domestify the
relationship between machine learning
and deep learning shedding light on
their unique characteristics and
dispelling any confusion surrounding
their usage hello guys I am mang and in
this video we will explore the
intricacies of these Technologies and
kick start your journey into
understanding of fascinating world of AI
just a quick info for you before moving
on what machine learning is if you want
to switch careers with AI and ml by
learning from the expert then try giving
simply learns postgrad program in Ai and
machine learning from P University in
collaboration with IBM this Ai and ml
course was delivered in collaboration
with P University and IBM learn in
demand skills such as machine learning
deep learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and many
more the link in the description box
should get to the homepage where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered so take action upskill and
get ahead so without any further Ado
let's get started so what is machine
learning these days we usually ask Siri
hey Siri how far is the nearest fuel
station whenever we ask something to
City the powerful speech recognition
system gets into work and converts the
audio into its textual form this is sent
to the Apple servers in the further
processing and then machine learning
algorithms are run to understand the
user intent and then finally CD tells
you the answer well this is happening
because of this machine learning machine
learning is a subart of artificial
intelligence the art of making computers
to learn and act like humans by feeding
data and making prediction based on the
experience as you saw in the previous
example when the data comes in machine
learning immediately start analyzing the
data and eventually get strained on it
and learns it when new data points come
in machines accurately make prediction
and decision based on the past data now
that we have understand what machine
learning is let's move forward and
discuss different types of machine
learning and algorithms 2024 so types of
machine learning machine learning is
classified into supervised learning
unsupervised learning and reinforcement
learning so now let's see some major
machine learning algorithms for 2024 so
there are two sort of problems in
supervised learning the first first one
is classification and regression so
certain types of machine learning
algorithms falls under the
classification are the first one is
decision algorithm KNN algorithm
logistic algorithm Nave based algorithm
support Vector machine svm and in
regression types of machine learning
algorithms are the first one is linear
regression the second one is regression
trees nonlinear regression basian linear
regression so moving forward so there
are two sorts of problems in un wise
learning the first one is clustering and
the second one is Association so in
clustering there are different types of
machine learning algorithms like first
one is K means clustering algorithm the
second one is principal component
analysis algorithm and the types of
machine learning algorithm that fall
under Association problems are the first
one is aiy algorithm the second one is
FP growth algorithm so the last
reinforcement learning in reinforcement
learning there are two types positive
reinforcement the negative one so
reinforcement learning are mainly used
in AI application and gaming application
the main use are Q learning State action
reward State action s r sa and in
negative one the Deep Q naral Network
and the mark of decision process so
moving forward let's discuss what is
deep learning so deep learning is a
subfield of machine learning that deals
with algorithm inspired by the structure
and the function of the brain and which
is part of artificial intelligence deep
learning is widely used to make weather
predictions about rain earthquakes and
the tsunamis it helps in taking
necessary precautions with deep learning
machines can comprehend speech and
provide the required output it enables
the machine to recognize people and
object in the mes to Fed to it deep
learning also help advertisers leverage
data to perform realtime biing and
targeted display advertising so now
moving forward let's discuss type of
neural network in 2024 the first first
one is feed forall Neal Network this is
the simplest form of Ann artificial Neal
network data travels only in One
Direction input to Output the second one
is radial basis function neural network
this model classifies the data point
based on the distance from a center
point if you don't have training data
for example you will want to group
things and create a center point the
network looks for data point that are
similar to each other and groups them
one of the application for this is power
restore ition system the third one is
cohon self-organizing neural network so
in this vectors of random input are
input to a discrete map comprised of
neurons vectors are also called
dimensions of planes application include
using it to recognize patterns in data
likee medical analysis the fourth one is
RNN recurrent neural network in this
type the hidden layer saves its output
to be used for future prediction the
output become part of its new input
application include text to speech
conversion the fifth one is CNN
convolutional neural NW in this type the
input features are taken in badges as if
they pass through a filter this allows
the network to remember an image in
parts so application include signal and
image processing such as facial
recognition the sixth one is modular
neural network this is composed of
collection of different neural network
working together to get output so this
is Cutting Edge and is still in the
research phas so moving forward we will
discuss some key differences between
machine learning and deep learning the
first one is human intervention in
contrast to traditional machine learning
where humans manually code features deep
Learning System autonomously learn
features like edges and facial component
in task such as facial recognition this
self trining process utilizing neural
networks a keen to the human brain
eliminates the need for human
intervention in recoding resulting in
improved accuracy over time the second
one is Hardware deep Learning System
demand more robust Hardware due to the
extensive data processing and complex
mathematical calculation in their
algorithm graphical processing unit gpus
are a specific type of Hardware employed
for deep learning whereas simpler
machine learning programs can operate on
less powerful machines the third one is
time given the extensive data and
numerous parameters involved deep
Learning Systems take a considerable
amount of of time to train while machine
learning may take seconds to hours deep
learning can span from hours to weeks
the fourth one is approach while machine
learning algorithm process data in parts
and combine them for a result whereas
deep Learning Systems stackle entire
problem at once for example identifying
objects in an image involves two steps
with machine learning object detection
and the recognition in contrast a deep
learning program after training provides
both identify object and their location
in the image in a single result so the
last one is application given the
distinctions mentioned earlier it's
clear that machine learning and deep
learning serve different purposes
machine learning finds use in predictive
program like email spam detection and
evidence-based medical treatment plans
on the other hand deep learning
examplified the application like Netflix
music streaming and the facial
recognition is prominently featured in
high-profile domain such as self-driving
cars here deep learning employs layer
neural network for task like object
recognition traffic light identification
and decision making so moving forward
let's see some machine learning and deep
learning future Trends so the future
hold Limitless possibilities for machine
learning and deep learning expects
increase use of robot not just in
manufacturing but also in enhancing our
daily lives in healthcare deep learning
may enable early concept prediction or
detection potentially saving lives
financially both machine learning and
deep learning apposition to Aid
companies and individuals in saving
money making wiser investment and
allocating resources efficiently so
these Trends are just the starting point
developers imaginations are sparking
innovation in numerous areas yet to be
explored so we have come to end of this
video if you have any question or doubt
you can comment down below our team of
experts will reach out to you as soon as
possible thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning with
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here